[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم روسيا تعلن احباط هجوم
بمسيره على موسكو وتقول ان الهجوم لم يوقع
اي اصابات في وقت اكدت فيه واشنطن
موافقتها على تزويد كياف بطائرات اف 16
وقالت اوكرانيا ان الحصول على المقاتلات
سيغير مجرى الحرب ولي العهد السعودي ووزير
الخارجيه الايراني يبحثان في جده تعزيز
العلاقات بين البلدين وفرص التعاون
المستقبليه والتطورات الاقليميه والدوليه
عبد الله هيان يصف المحادثات بالصريحه
والمثمره وذلك غداه محادثات ايرانيه
سعوديه في الرياض اكدت حرص الطرفين على
تفعيل التعاون وحل الملفات العالقه
السلطات الامريكيه تواصل محاولات التعرف
على هويات اكثر من 100 ضحيه لحرائق هاواي
وسطى توقعات بارتفاع عدد الضحايا مع بقاء
1300 شخص في عداد المفقودين في حين اعلن
مدير اداره الطوارئ في ماوي [__] بعد
انتقادات له بشان قراره عدم تفعيل سفره
الانذار الاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم يعلن
لائحه المرشحين الثلاثيه لجائزه افضل لاعب
في اوروبا لموسم
2022-2023 حيث ستكون المنافسه بين
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي والبلجيكي كيفن دي
بروين والنرويجي ايرلينج الى اللقاء